[Musique]
depuis dix ans le parc floral s'est
converti au bio
une méthode de culture particulièrement
ardue dans la serre aux papillons avec
son climat tropical
c'est un mélange il ya plusieurs
occident qui attaquent aussi bien les
pucerons les cochenilles où les ou les
araignées donc dans ce même tube voilà
vous avez plusieurs auxiliaires
c'est ainsi d'alu biologique entièrement
biologiques parce que dans la serre
comme on est en présence de papillons
bon bah on peut pas mettre de produits
chimiques et puis doucement au parc
floral depuis des années on met pas deux
pour lui si mik ici la lutte biologique
doit s'adapter aux cycles du papillon ça
veut dire chouchouter des chenilles
pourtant terriblement vorace s'éduque
hâtif pour le public pour savoir qui ont
fait de lui biologique mais au fond on
laisse aussi les papillons se reproduire
dans la serre de même et donc manger et
donc manger donc c'est vrai que quand la
fin il vous fait manger je vais la
coupée mais on laisse après les hôtes
pour qu'elle soit ils soient mangés par
les papilles m
[Musique]
à l'extérieur entretenir un jardin
potager en bio semble maintenant un jeu
d'enfant je trouve qu'on apprend
beaucoup plus plutôt que d'utiliser un
produit chimique pour traiter simplement
un problème que l'on fait que repousser
là on va chercher des solutions
naturelles observer beaucoup plus et
comprendre comment la nature fonctionne
et ça marche ça marche
après il faut toujours accepter en
pourcentage de perte parce que ça ça
fait partie du bio les 35 hectares du
parc floral sont conduits sans produits
chimiques
un mode de culture bio réalisé par les
jardiniers mais qui demande aussi une
compréhension de la part des visiteurs
je dirais que c'est pédagogique dans le
sens où déjà on fait une tonte
différencier ça permet aussi au public
de voir que on entretient toujours parce
qu'il ya une zone qui est ont dû
régulièrement
et puis il ya une deuxième jaune qui est
plus laisser sauvage en fait ça permet
aussi au public de voir que ben la main
du jardinier elle est toujours présente
écologique et pédagogique
c'est la vocation du parc floral porté
par les jardiniers bio